i'm going to start with congratulations
to the two of you i thought you both did
such a great job in the film
um so uh i want to jump into i'm a big
fan of george as both an
actor and as a director i'm curious what
he is like
on set uh is he more like clint eastwood
where he's doing one or two takes and
moving on
or is he more like a fincher doing a lot
of takes
oh no he's definitely more clint
eastwood
um he i think he's someone who
really appreciates when other people put
value on his time and so therefore he
very much treats everyone else around
him
in the way he would like to be treated
it's not that you feel
rushed it's just that he absolutely
knows what he's after and he allows
for preparation he makes sure that the
script
gets you in time a lot of the time what
you're dealing with is just
logistically and practically you're
being given sides on the day and
there's not a lot of respect around what
it takes for an actor to give a good
performance
and in ways that are almost
imperceptible
george creates an environment where you
get to do your work
well and so it means by the time you get
to the the
set you're actually as prepared as you
need to be for him to be able to
move things along quite quickly and so
it's actually a very seamless
incredibly civilized um
way of working switching gears uh one of
the things
that i like about movies is when they
don't answer every question
the imagination is always better than
what uh you know an explanation
saying that i am curious if the two of
you for each of you
came up with your own theories as to
what actually happened on the planet
yeah i mean it was interesting
from what i can remember george was
quite uh careful and not he didn't want
it to be he didn't want to get
too specific and too stuck into the
details of what has
what had happened it was very much that
there had been
an apocalyptic moment um that obviously
when you see that vision of earth
you know it's pretty bad um but i think
we presume there'd been some sort of
nuclear explosion uh something
in that in that vein i mean it would
have been interesting if it had been a
worldwide pandemic and then then we'd
have
you know no they would think we started
it felicity
exactly the biggest publicity stunt of
all time
oh actually for both of you uh i'm uh
curious what is it like
watching a movie like this for the first
time because you weren't on set
for half the movie so there has to be
like a reaction for you that you really
don't know
what how it was filmed or what people
were doing on the day
so for each of you can you talk about
your reaction seeing the finished film
for me it was almost like i was only in
a quarter of the movie
because yes you have the george clooney
in the
with the little girl in iceland and all
that craziness but
for us so much of the film
um or our section of the film was built
after we had shot our stuff in terms of
vfx
obviously we're shooting in space and so
therefore space
has to now be inputted into the the film
even though
we were interacting with that
environment obviously not being in that
environment
so you know there are occasionally these
films where
you are just as awed by watching the
film as the audience
around you you know i i watched it with
my wife and she looked at my expression
now and again it was almost as if i
hadn't been there when we were shooting
the film
because it was just so awe-inspiring i
was so impressed by the fact that george
was in that
unbelievable environment um while
directing and acting and just being so
cold
but then just so impressive what uh the
the visual effects of the film were
after we had shot our stuff as well
yeah it was um it was actually yeah it
was
fascinating watching it and just how
beautifully constructed it was and how
artful it is
and you know that opening sequence with
the blood uh
running around as as george's is um
doing the the chemotherapy i really was
totally
struck by that imagery because you never
quite know how a film is gonna
turn out but um but just and exploring
such
personal themes and felt i mean it's
incredibly
moving and paxa packs a huge punch by
the end of the film
but it was i mean particularly watching
it now in the in the moment that we find
ourselves in it's
just yeah you're watching it looking for
hope and
looking for answers to this situation
that we find ourselves in